[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département c'est parti
pour le sommaire handball plaisir n'y
arrive pas des plaisirs oies se sont
inclinés ce week-end face à haguenau
dans leur gymnase une défaite qu'il y
fait redescendre à la dernière place de
nationale 3 plus de détails dans ce
magazine karting jim il ya dix ans
affole toujours les compteurs le jeune
prodige originaire de guyancourt est à
l'aube d'une nouvelle saison nous ferons
le point avec lui sur ses ambitions pour
cette année 2010 9 et ses projets futurs
basket bamba cei est de retour dans les
yvelines l'intérieur joueurs l'intérieur
joueur star de trappes au début des
années 2000 a signé ou chine versailles
l'été dernier son portrait dans quelques
instants
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
on commence donc par du handball
quatrième défaite consécutive pour
plaisir dans le championnat de nationale
3 les plaisirs oies se sont inclinés ce
dimanche à domicile contre haguenau une
défaite qui les fait redescendre à la
dernière place du championnat
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
à un montage de romain aarhus fini la
série noire continue pour plaisir les
jaune et noir ont concédé une quatrième
défaite de suite en nationale 3 les
plaisirs oies se sont inclinés contre
haguenau sur le score de 35 à 31 ce
dimanche à domicile les plaisirs aux a
mené pourtant le 3 buts à la fin de la
première période beaucoup d'amertume
parce que on man à plusieurs reprises de
quatre buts et
on remet systématiquement l'adversaire
en selle en ayant bien trop d'échecs
passes ratées tirs manqués sur des
solutions où l'adversaire n'a pas
forcément provoquer notre note
défaillance après bon l'adversaire s'est
battu jusqu'au bout non qui mérite sa
victoire ça va là le débat mais on donne
beaucoup trop de cartouches à notre
adversaire
cette défaite face à un adversaire
direct dans la course au maintien aura
peut-être de lourdes conséquences pour
la suite du championnat
les plaisirs oies sont actuellement
lanterne rouge de la poule avec
seulement deux victoires depuis le début
de la saison à venir c'est le boulot
déjà costaud aux vaillants et puis qu'on
retrouve nos valeurs parce que là je
trouve qu'on perd vraiment notre emballé
à cette mentalité qu'on avait et
dernière qui nous a permis d'atteindre
les barrages pour la nationale 2
prochain match pour plaisir le dimanche
27 janvier toujours à domicile face à un
autre concurrent direct pour le maintien
thionville moselle handball l'avant
dernier du championnat
victoire impérative pour continuer à
croire au maintien en fin de saison
toujours en balles mais cette fois ci à
chez les filles monti le bretonneux
continue sa marche en avant les hymnes
talent reporté une deuxième victoire
consécutive sur le terrain du paris
saint germain ce week end les joueuses
de denys choulet se sont imposés 26 à 23
grâce notamment à 8 réalisations de
justin ribouleau au classement les
saint-quentinoises remontée se retrouve
maintenant la 7e place du classement
avec 20 points à quatre petits points du
podium
ont joué est également sur les terrains
de rugby ce week end dans le championnat
de fédérale 2 plaisir n'a pas pu
résister au rouleau compresseur horse et
les plaisirs oies se sont inclinés 33 à
0 à l'extérieur ce dimanche dans un
match à sens unique
au classement les hommes de sébastien
roques elle y reste à la 9e place avec
cinq points de plus que le premier
relégable
deux divisions plus bas dans le
championnat honneur verseille n'en finit
plus de gagner 11 victoires en onze
matches disputés cette saison pour les
versaillais
ils se sont imposés ce week-end face à
gif-sur-yvette dans un match à sens
unique également les joueurs de la cité
royale compte désormais 12 points
d'avancé sur leur dauphin montesson
l'afp la montée en fédérale 3 n'a jamais
été aussi proche
toujours dans le championnat honneur
mais cette fois ci dans la poule 2 le
sky rugby continue à réaliser de belles
prestations les saint quentinois se sont
imposé 23-7 face à garches vaucresson ce
dimanche de son côté chez rose n'a pu
faire mieux qu'un match nul sur son
terrain dans le
erbi vinoy faso mlsgp au classement le
sky est cinquième avec 29 points chauds
rose reste sur le podium avec 34 points
depuis le début de la saison on ouvre
maintenant une page sport automobile la
saison de karting va recommencer d'ici
quelques semaines et un ebe noah devrait
une nouvelle fois faire des étincelles
je veux bien sûr parler de jimmy elias à
10 ans le gluant courtois affole les
compteurs chez l'équipe tony kart
nous avons la chance de le recevoir sur
ce plateau ainsi que son père cyrille et
bias bonsoir
alors comment te sens tu à la proche de
cette nouvelle année très bien j'espère
gagner beaucoup de courses c'est c'est
bien le karting
j'adore sa basse pression non pas du
tout cyril coomans me sentais super
qu'il côtoyait forcément au quotidien il
a beaucoup évolué
grâce en partie à son manager christophe
perrin l usine tony kart qui sont
vraiment je pense une référence dans le
monde du karting aujourd'hui
techniquement il a énormément évolué il
a pris conscience aussi qu'il fallait
parler les langues donc ils travaillent
l'anglais il fait beaucoup de sport et
il se prépare sérieusement pour ce grand
challenge 2019 il ya eu des changements
un petit peu dans sa préparation comparé
aux autres années voyez bien sûr donc
il a pris conscience que l'anglais était
très important donc fait trois heures
d'anglais par semaine en plus de l'école
justement jimmy c'est pas trop dur non
pas du tout tu es bilingue maintenant
presque oui oui donc l'anglais
la préparation physique aussi don qui
est très importante et ensuite
son alimentation il travaille beaucoup
il a vraiment là une volonté de travail
impressionnante à son âge on est limite
dans un cadre professionnel maintenant
avec jimmy pas encore alors on essaye de
faire en sorte qu'ils gardent sa vie
d'enfant mais il a il a vraiment il a ça
dans le sang que je veux dire il a
vraiment le sport auto dans le sang et
de lui même il a besoin
il a besoin de suivre
que ça soit la f1 le karting son
physique tout il est il est vraiment moi
il m'impressionne la fondation jimmy tu
penses que c'est un moment déterminant
dans une saison la préparation
l'intersaison que comme on l'appelle
très bien j'adore ça c'est bien
cyril il ira pour jouer la gagne
l'année prochaine oui bien sûr façon
jimmy il a vraiment un tempérament de
gagnant il deuxième ça lui plaît pas
trop c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le
but de gagner donc maintenant il ya des
paramètres par rapport à a
son écurie son usine par rapport à la
concurrence il travaille beaucoup il
développe il a dossier lusine aller dans
une direction et ça il a très bien
compris on va jouer la gagne je pense
que il est prêt maintenant est plus qu à
jimmy commenté camarades de classe tu te
perçoivent bal avec toi de karting oui
beaucoup
très bien moi il dit je te fais fort tu
pourrais gagner le championnat du monde
et j'espère était professeur également
c'est important aussi pour jimmy qu'il
est un environnement sain on peut un peu
dire autour de lui il à son manager du
coup christophe perrin on n'a pas pu
venir ce soir malheureusement est
également vous sa famille qui voit là
que vous devez créer une espèce de bulle
autour de lui c'est ça ouais alors on
est une famille de passionnés dans sport
automobile maintenant c'est une passion
quand je vois un enfant qui vient
d'avoir dix ans aussi passionné et qui
ya une volonté comme il a c'est vrai que
alors on fait la part des choses bien sa
partie un petit peu enfants on laisse un
petit peu vivre ses moments de loisirs
mais il rentre directement dans l' il
est il a besoin d'eux il est vrai enfin
il a vraiment une envie qui dépasse
l'entendement jimmy jimmy est ce que tu
préfères ton karting avant les courses
oui je fais du sport de l'anglais un peu
d'italien beaucoup du sport et au niveau
mécanique
est-ce que tu prépares tonton carte en
lui-même un peu également oui c'est
important aussi qui les sept touches
mécaniques on va dire oui oui donc ce
qui est important c'est le
elle a bien compris c'est de donner des
bonnes informations à l'origine
notamment de travailler à la télé mais
trinh chose qui l'a bien compris et avec
son mécanicien d'avoir des vrais un vrai
ressenti pour les pour les emmener dans
la bonne direction
et pour ça il a il a vraiment un truc
qu'il a il arriva il sort du car qui
peut vraiment avec précision décrire son
kart au mécano est ce qu'il a un
carburateur est ce que en moteur est ce
qu'on châssis s compression n'est pas
bien et ça jimmy arrive vraiment à
vraiment ma maison son karting au point
tout seul c'est dans ces tops jimmy tu
es un grand fan de lewis hamilton est ce
que tu penses qu'il te reste encore
beaucoup de chemin à parcourir avant
d'arriver à son niveau
ouais oui beaucoup beaucoup de cheveux
beaucoup qu'est ce qui te plaît chez lui
tombe à cette donne un bon exemple
les champions du monde c'est c'est un
bon exemple c'est nous penser qu'il peut
atteindre un jour le niveau d'un lewis
hamilton
je vais vous dire sincèrement c'est
délicat ont tant que père de parler d'un
enfant de son enfant parce que
généralement les parents seront toujours
les parents leur fils est le meilleur
maintenant effectué son grand frère qui
avait la chance de rouler que pierre
gasly esteban aux cons qui avait charles
leclerc qui était en une génération très
très bonne génération de grand talent je
vous dirai en tant que passionné
pas en tant que père qui m impressionne
par sa volonté
l'intelligence qu'il a dans sport
automobile et surtout sa vitesse
maintenant je pense que je pense
vraiment qu'il a 2 qu'il a un gros
potentiel et c'est difficile d'en parler
banque permet mais à son âge
un sondage il va dans le bon sens il va
vraiment dans le bon sens jimmy déjà
sollicité par des grosses écuries aux
côtés aujourd'hui là il a un manager qui
est extraordinaire qui va avec il faut
un super travail
heureusement qu'on a des gens contents
d'expérience du sport automobile pour
pouvoir un peu nous emmener dans la
bonne direction
je pense que qu'il a certaines idées et
après je ne sais pas exactement où il en
est à ce niveau-là mais mais je suis sûr
qu'il va y arriver
est-ce que tu as une petite préférence
pour une écurie en particulier tony kart
est très bien c'est très bien tony kart
pour l'instant est peut-être une grosse
écurie de merci à tous les deux
d'être passé sur ce plateau
je suis une dernière phrase j'aimerais
bien remercier manager christophe caron
et j'ai pu lire ce soir malheureusement
malheureusement toute l'équipe tenue
carte de steam et à ma famille et mes
proches
le message est passé merci beaucoup
jimmy merci merci cyril on soit de
réaliser une très belle saison il espère
que jimmy tu auras de nouvelles coupes
mettre dans votre chambre à la fin de la
saison
merci du football à présent ont joué ce
week-end sur les pelouses de régionale 3
l'étoile sportive de trappes a été tenu
en échec par le club des mureaux à
l'extérieur le score 1 partout à la fin
du temps réglementaire un résultat qui
n'arrange pas les trappistes promis
avant cette rencontre trappe et
d'aujourd'hui
troisième à un point du leader boulogne
billancourt du football encore mais
cette fois ci américain tout va bien
pour les templiers d'elancourt deuxième
victoire en deux matches pour les
aidants courtois dans le championnat de
deuxième division ils se sont imposés 36
à 0 ce week end sur le t1 des diables
rouges de villepinte cette victoire
permet aux saint quentinois d'occuper la
première place de leur poule prochain
match le 9 février à domicile contre les
myrmidon de savigny-le-temple un mot de
basket à présent dans ce championnat de
nationale 3 trappe continue sa bonne
dynamique les trappistes se sont imposés
sur leur parquet contre angers sur le
score de 81 à 59
une victoire qui permet aux saint
quentinois de croire en une montée en
fin de saison l'équipe est actuellement
deuxième avec 2 points de retard sur le
premier à poitiers on continue à parler
de basket et le trap il a été l'un des
joueurs majeurs de cette équipe au début
des années 2000 bamba cei est de retour
dans les yvelines depuis l'été dernier
le basketteur d'un mètre 98 a signé au
chesnay versailles portrait de ce joueur
hors du commun un montage du michael
jordan des monteurs faisait déjà là il
fait son come back dans les yvelines le
basketteur bamba cei 39 ans a rejoint
les rangs du chesnay versailles l'été
dernier après avoir joué avant nationale
son objectif relever un dernier défi
avec le club de r avant de raccrocher
ses baskets
je me suis dit que je vais venir à
versailles pour essayer de d'aider
l'équipe à remonter parce qu'ils ont
très très bon projet que je voulais à
berrer au futur c'est plus qu'une plus
value ses limites un miracle que dizaine
qui vient de jouer avec nous étant donné
qu'il était encore l'année dernière en
national de quoi avant de signer au
chesnay versailles bamba cei a connu une
carrière riche international sénégalais
avec une quinzaine de sélection jouera
également marqué l'histoire d'un autre
club aubinois situe à moins de 15
kilomètres le fc trappes saint quentin
en yvelines
le numéro 11 a rejoint la structure en
2002 à l'âge de 22 ans
une équipe familiale et que tout le
monde on s'entraide et les dirigeants
les joueurs tout le monde donc en fait
c'était une équipe familiale
le franco-sénégalais d'un mètre
quatre-vingt dix-huit réussir à emmener
le club trappistes en nationale une
grâce à des prestations de haute volée
le basketteur restera au total sept ans
dans la structure malgré les
sollicitations qui est un peu fidèle et
je pouvais aller jouer au dessus et je
pouvais aller tenter ma chance ailleurs
mais ben je voulais grandir avec mais
qui me frappe
est ce qu'on a fait je garde nationale
aujourd'hui à presque 40 ans l'intérieur
veut avant tout prendre du plaisir sur
les parquets et partager son expérience
avec ses coéquipiers du chesnay
versailles
bamba s'improvise même parfois
entraîneur adjoint quand il le faut et
de suie et tu prends l'écran je peux pas
m'empêcher sûr mais si je vois des trucs
que je suis obligé de le parler des
vacances et je pense qu'il veut comme il
le fait de manière très respectueuse et
il essaie de rester toujours à sa place
donc on en a beaucoup discuté et c'est
même moi qui l'incitent à vient me voir
et ne pas hésiter à donner des conseils
si besoin bamba cei voudrait continuer à
transmettre son savoir après sa carrière
en l'entraînant des genoux en réalisant
des camps de basket caritatif avec son
association sauf hadji au sénégal mais
avant tout il veut continuer à jouer
pour emmener le chesnay-versailles le
plus haut possible de la course à pied
la 12e édition de la bike and run du roi
était organisée ce dimanche matin autour
de la pièce d'eau des suisses de
versailles
plus de 300 coureurs venus des yvelines
et de l'île de france ont participé à
cette compétition
le concept chaque duo devait alterner
entre de la course à pied le vélo
pendant les 12 km du parcours
à ce petit jeu là ce sont les deux
coéquipiers du club de palaiseau romain
pozzo di borgo et quentin amaral qui
l'ont emporté ils ont réussi à boucler
leur périple en 40 minutes et deux
secondes on écoute leur réaction au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
on est toujours surpris de gier est
d'une victoire il n'y a rien d'acquis en
tout cas au départ on a eu de la chance
de se détacher rapidement dès le début
de la course et du coup après on avait
serré un peu plus de je dirais de marche
pour gérer à notre rythme selon le
dénivelé du parcours et c'est donc c'est
assez ça fait toujours plaisir c'est une
belle victoire
on passe maintenant notre chronique
junior si vous cherchez une activité
pour vos enfants ne paniquez pas notre
journaliste mélanie poké vous donne
chaque mois des idées de sport pour les
tout-petits et elle nous a rejoint sur
ce plateau bonsoir on sent week-end
alors aujourd'hui nous allons parler
handball les grands champions français
ont tous commencé à pratiquer très tôt
cette discipline nikola karabatic a fait
ses premiers pas en club à 6 ans à
strasbourg thielland meilleur à 9 ans au
club de cerner en alsace en cette
période de championnat du monde mélanie
poké vous aider à les nous parler du
bégayante sur saint quentin en yvelines
et oui à la smb donc à
montigny-le-bretonneux il ya une section
qui a été créé il ya trois ans pour les
enfants âgés de 3 à 6 ans donc on peut
même commencer plus tôt que les
champions les entraînements ont lieu
tous les samedis entre midi et 14 heures
et un créneau encadrés par les
entraîneurs du club et les bénévoles
basé sur sur le jeu c'est d'apprendre à
écouter d'apprendre à respecter les
règles d'apprendre aussi à être le faire
du sport en collectivité ça c'est la
première des choses
au début c'est pas toujours facile parce
que les enfants vont recouvrir dans les
bras de papa maman mais ils écoutent ils
arrivent ils arrivent à être à
s'autodiscipliner et je précise que les
parents ne sont pas obligés de laisser
les enfants sur les deux heures est ce
que les jeunes ou de la compétition mais
on ne tire pas encore le baby hand c'est
avant tout de l'apprentissage
il faut courir seul puis avec un ballon
faire des dribbles puise puis des passes
et gestes techniques comme le tir
arrivent petit à petit et très vite
certains enfants deviennent aussi
gardien alors pour mettre tous en
pratique de cours matchs sont organisées
mais le mieux c'est d'écouter lui les
participants un papa et l'entraînement
et l'entraîneur du baby
match
on s'amuse c'est plutôt pas mal et
commence à se débrouiller avec les
ballons donc tout va bien en leur
inculquant les valeurs du sport
l'entrée de la solidarité
le vivre ensemble progressent très très
très vite donc on a vraiment des
résultats en termes de motricité de jeu
collectif
li progressent beaucoup plus vite que
les adultes l'idée est bien sûr de
s'amuser avoir de base le plus important
surtout donc les bonnes bases ça permet
après d'entrer plus facilement dans les
catégories d'âge et le club de montigny
le bretonneux est peut-être en train de
former une future pépite
merci beaucoup mais la nuit on vous
retrouvera le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle console chronique consacrée aux
juniors on passe maintenant notre page
agenda
[Musique]
pour débuter cette page agenda jo
propose de prendre le large le skipper
versailles et éric bellion sera ce jeudi
soir à 20 heures au cirano de versailles
navigateur présentera en avant première
son documentaire baptisé comme un seul
homme qui sortira dans les salles le 13
février prochain le film retrace son
aventure lors du vendée globe 2017
regardez la bande annonce
[Musique]
bateau tout heureux
c'est abandonner
s'en faut
[Musique]
j'ai cassé mon second est lui déniant la
du gros gros dégâts
[Musique]
il
leader s'arrête je sais pas
en poule dont
je voulais rentrer en disant que tu
étais merveille
vous
j'ai trouvé ce que je cherchais
j'ai aucun regret et en tant qu'homme
shell et au delà de ce que je pensais
[Musique]
je prêche pleure toute l'âme et les
avants
[Musique]
retour sur terre nous allons maintenant
parler de course à pied et plus
précisément du cross de la sablière qui
est programmée le 17 février prochain
entre viroflay versailles pour nous
parler de ce rendez-vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau le président de l'usf
viroflay jean pierre houillez ainsi que
l'un des participants antonin bortolotti
bonsoir son sort alors est-ce que tout
est prêt avec quelques semaines
d'organiser cette épreuve bien sûr
comment tout est une assurent près comme
mai au cannet derrière parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de nouveautés cette année on
aura un nouveau logo nouvelle affiche
par contre parcours identiques à ceux de
l'année dernière et on a aussi une
nouveauté c est d aller les
entraînements qui sont prévues ou le
recours à cause du parcours qui sont
prévues les deux week-end précédant
l'épreuve
et puis bon naturellement je pense plus
de participants que l'année dernière
puisque nous aurons les sportifs anciens
sont donc appelés d'une l'espoir le club
des plans 10 sport le sport adapté les
bouchons de l'espoir et lille 78 et
sport adapté 78 et enfin nous avons
aussi des marais des animations dans les
écoles primaires de viroflay pour
effectivement suscité le désir d enfant
qui prononce un sourire voilà ça tous
avaient alors le parcours ne change pas
antonin comment il est ce parcours ans
un parcours qui est très intéressant
dans un très beau cadre la forêt donc
c'est un parcours qui est assez
technique avec beaucoup de dénivelé
donc comme la course a lieu en février
il faut bien sûr prévoir des bonnes
chaussures pour éviter tout ce qui est
bout c est donc c'est vraiment un moment
très intéressant du point de vue sportif
et technique
les difficultés du coup c'est quoi donc
c'est surtout la dénivelée qu'on
retrouve des montées plutôt costaud et
bien sûr les descentes qui vont avec
il faut beaucoup s'entraîner ou pas pour
ce type d'épreuve
vous êtes un grand sportif un bouge au
football notamment beaucoup s'entraîner
et un entraînement quotidien suffit pas
ce qui est vraiment intéressant dans le
cross c'est que on peut retrouver tous
les sports c'est comme c'est le cardio
qui prime c'est vrai multi sports donc
moi je conseille vraiment devenir haut
aux séances pour préparer le parcours
pour vraiment repérer les difficultés et
les moments où il faudra accélérer le
jour de la course
jean-pierre oui vous êtes d'accord avec
cantona oui bien sûr c'est la
malheureuse en une grosse préparation
non mais l'autre mais c'est quand même
une préparation a pas oui pour tenir à
distance mais aussi comme la difficulté
qui est près de qom a effectivement la
boue en février que l'année dernière
bons disquaires qui fera bien sûr beau
et apparemment on est parti pour une
perte de froid donc froid et bruce est
l'idéal pour le cross-country
alors je vais vous montrer une image un
article paru chez nos confrères des
nouvelles de versailles en 1978 qu'est
ce que cela vous inspire
bassam à 1972 ma première participation
en cause de la sablière à la deuxième
édition du cross de la sablière et ça
m'inspire effectivement après que bon
monfils l'a fait en école primaire
il l'a fait l'année dernière aussi et
puis bon j'espère aussi c'est le
l'histoire du cross à viroflay c'est à
dire que toutes les générations le font
les unes après les autres
j'allais dire à viroflay le sport le
cross-country et le cross de la sablière
c'est obligatoire c'est devenu vraiment
un rendez vous encore incontournable à
viroflay et même dans les yvelines
oui bien sûr parce que d'abord on
accueille quand même chaque année plus
de 1000 participants
donc on essaie aussi de développer
effectivement au delà de tous les
publics
et c'est aussi intergénérationnel parce
que les parents les enfants les mamans
et c'est tout le monde peut y participer
et donc je pense qu'effectivement
c'était au delà c'est vraiment mon très
conviviale très festif et je pense que
c'est maintenant comment rentrer en
rentrer vraiment dans le paysage sportif
et au plaisir et maintenant cette course
est inscrite au challenge fédéral des
courses hors stade
pour les licenciés de la fédération
française d'athlétisme c'est un plus en
force et c'est une nouveauté pour les
compétiteurs vraiment qu'ils veulent
effectivement faire un parcours cros
tout au long de l'hiver précédent +
effectivement pour ce public là alors
très rapidement est ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire
oui bien sûr on peut s'inscrire plus que
jamais il faut se faire sur le site
ancestry.com on pourra aussi le faire
bien sûr par la poste ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas aussi sur place la veille au
siège du club
hossa des berti 7 et puis sur place le
dimanche matin une demi heure avant le
début de chaque course
merci à tous les deux dépassé sur ce
plateau bon courage pour l'organisation
on sait qu'elle va forcément simple nous
donnerons évidemment les résultats de la
compétition dans un futur à 7,8 sport un
autre rendez vous à noter dans vos
agendas il y aura du cyclisme ce
week-end avec la finale de la coupe
d'hiver sur piste au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines lui club
francilien seront présents pour cette
troisième édition dont le vc montigny le
bretonneux et le cv l'isi au programme
de l'omnium et de la vitesse
individuelle de la catégorie juniors
élite
si vous voulez assister à l'événement le
tarif est à 3 euros
il y aura également du football à ce
week-end avec la première division de
district guyancourt deuxième du
championnat reçoit le 17ème le chesnay
pour un match qui sent la poudre
les deux équipes visent une montée en
fin de saison et ne sont séparés que par
3 petits points
si vous voulez assister à ce choc le
match est programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade maurice baquet du
football mais cette fois-ci virtuel
avant de refermer cette émission les
manettes étaient de sortie ce week-end à
jouy en josas
le club de football de l'ue sj organisé
la deuxième édition de son tournoi fifa
sur consoles de jeux l'événement attiré
près d'une quarantaine de participants
avec des matchs retransmis et commentée
sur les réseaux sociaux on écoute les
réactions des deux finalistes dans la
catégorie adulte mais juste avant l'un
des meilleurs moments de ce tournoi un
but marqué dans les toutes dernières
secondes de la demi finale
regardez stade le temps d'espérer
peut-être le temps d'une contre attaque
et gareth bale est encore blessé gareth
bale qui la transporte à vinisud junior
à luka modric luka modric
peut-être qu'il va pouvoir la passer sur
le côté à marca satio sûrement la
dernière occasion de ce taux de ce match
parce que c'est ce qu'il passe pas comme
ça c'est ce qui me plaît
richemont
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est complètement fou sais pas si ces
points
fasciné temps
je suis très content maillot je suis un
grand fan de foot jeu pourra demander un
beau maillot c'est un événement qui me
tient à coeur pour faire développer le
club et le mettre en avant pour toucher
beaucoup de personnes je suis plus venu
pour l'ambiance le fait d'être 2e 1er
voilà c'était pas ça l'important je me
suis régalé ce soir c'était génial
c'est ce qui compte c'est la fin de
cette émission très belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]